[Musique]
les puissances coloniales ont longtemps
convoité les richesses de l'amérique du
sud
le bois précieux l'or ce sont finalement
les espagnols et les portugais qui ont
mis la main sur le continent ou presque
au nord-est les britanniques les
hollandais et les français ont réussi à
se conserver une petite enclave sur
l'océan
trois petits territoires au bord de
l'immense forêt amazonienne
trois petits pays exotiques qui se
ressemblent mais qui reste bien à part
et qui ont du mal à communiquer il y à
la barrière des langues mais aussi des
cultures le guyana independent or depuis
1966 est resté dans le fond très
britannique
[Musique]
nul doute le guyana est un pays caraïbe
peuplé de la même façon que les autres
anciennes colonies britanniques esclaves
noirs et après l'abolition importations
de travailleurs en servitude des indes
britanniques
une population qui se mélange bien un
peuple uni sauf au moment des élections
et nous y sommes
l'enjeu politique n'a jamais été aussi
grand pour le guyana ce petit pays de
750 mille habitants deviendra dès 2020
progressivement un grand exportateur de
pétrole
c'est le gros lot pour le parti qui
gagnera l'élection et le pouvoir pour
longtemps dans un pays notoirement
corrompu la perspective d'un partage
équitable de la nouvelle richesse laisse
beaucoup de guyane est sceptique
pas facile de gagner le pays voisin le
surinam à partir de georgetown pas de
service d'autobus seulement des minibus
privés qui passent 30 des clients qui
ont réservé au téléphone départ 4 heures
du matin pour ne pas rater le traversier
un traversier vétuste qui s'y prendre à
deux fois pour accoster au surinam à
cause du fort courant du fleuve couronne
times
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un dimanche pas comme les autres
dans la cathédrale saints pierre et paul
de paramaribo
[Musique]
à
un dimanche de première communion le
service bien sûr se fait en néerlandais
notre langue c'est tout les choses
l'éducation lander nous pensons à nos
langues
les planteurs hollandais étaient
particulièrement cruel avec leurs
esclaves africains
résultat un grand nombre de marrons des
esclaves échappée qui se sont cachés
dans la forêt amazonienne
ivan béraud est un descendant de marron
il a perdu un oeil dans un jeu d'enfant
quand il avait 11 ans dans le village de
son grand-père santig ron ivn a retrouvé
des cousins qu'il ne connaissait pas les
marrons constitue une force politique
incontournable surinam
ils ont été les victimes d'une guerre
civile dans les années 80 marquée par le
massacre de dizaines d'entre eux a movie
you wanna près de la frontière de la
guyane française
[Applaudissements]
c'était sous la dictature militaire de
désiré bouterse est élu légitimement
président en 2010 et réélu en 2015 un
personnage un peu sulfureux il a été
condamné à 14 ans de prison aux pays-bas
pour trafic de drogue
c'est pour ça qu'ils hésitent à quitter
le pays et il vient d'être condamné à 20
ans de prison pour meurtre
[Musique]
il a fait appel et il pourrait bien se
faire réélire en 2020 ce qui garantirait
son immunité
il pourrait se faire élire malgré une
économie désastreuse cela n'empêche pas
le surinam et paramaribo sa capitale
avec son architecture de bois classé
patrimoine de l'humanité d'être un pays
accueillant agréable goûter le fleuve
maroni c'est la frontière entre le
surinam et la guyane française pour les
gouvernements c'est une barrière pour
les gens d'un côté comme de l'autre le
fleuve c'est leur autoroute alors nous
avons fait comme tout le monde et nous
avons traversé le marronnier en pirogue
la journaliste c'est la carte s nous a
immédiatement présenté son compagnon il
a 27 ans et c'est le premier député le
plus jeunes de guyane
il est également tout comme avec 24 au
surinam le député français descendants
de marot moi je suis moche ning donc mes
parents sont originaires nos fleuves
dont on consomme afrodescendants
bushinengués vient de l'anglais bush
[ __ ] [ __ ] de la brousse disait ton en
français du côté sur une amère aussi on
retrouve le maran sont vos des deux
rives d'ailleurs on a d'ailleurs ces
femmes attendent ou bureau de l'aide
sociale c'est le jour des allocations
familiales
beaucoup viennent du surinam en donnant
naissance en guyane française le bébé
devient français et la famille
bénéficient de la généreuse aide sociale
française
à l'origine la france a voulu peuple et
sa colonie avec des bagnards qui aurait
dû rester à la fin de leur peine
échec ils mourraient trop
le bagne de guyane est resté jusqu'à sa
fermeture en 1948 la honte de l'afrique
la guyane ces peuples et d'anciens
esclaves de martiniquais et aussi de
vietnamiens après la guerre du vietnam
ce sont eux les maraîchers de la guyane
une population très variée comme on le
voit au marché de cayenne la capitale
250 mille habitants seulement sur un
territoire gigantesque qui se sentent
isolés et incompris
on est ici dans un pays apparaît en ce
sens à part parce que le développement
ici pour l'avoir il faut cravacher
il faut se battre il faut constamment
tapé du poing sur la table pour se
sentir européen pour se sentir français
[Applaudissements]
la guyane a tapé sur la table en 2010
cette grève générale et paralysie
complète
paris près enfin l'oreille et le
président emmanuel macron promet plus
d'autonomie
les guyanais aimerait par exemple
profiter des retombées économiques du
centre spatial de kourou fleurons
français de l'agencé spatiale européenne
3 guyane trois solitudes l'une
départements français doit regarder vers
paris il n'y a pas de vols vers les
autres guyane seulement ce petit
traversier lagabrielle sur le moroni
le surinam regarde vers les pays-bas où
réside le tiers de ses citoyens et enfin
le guyana se sent plus proche des autres
anciennes indes occidentales britannique
que de la mère patrie
mais les guyanes autant commun une forêt
amazonienne et des populations indigènes
le long des fleuves grandiose et un défi
de taille les chercheurs d'or
clandestins des orpailleurs souvent
venus du brésil et qui détruisent les
cours d'eau par des versements de
mercure
[Musique]
oh